[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans l'ue
cette ut loisirs merci de nous retrouver
pour cette émission dédiée à vos idées
sorties tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 8 décembre une semaine dédiée à
la musique baroque à montigny le
bretonneux conférences concerts et
rencontres vont rythmer la ville
jusqu'au 16 décembre avec en point
d'orgue le concert de françois
lazarevitch flûtiste de renommée
internationale nous en parlerons avec
notre invité à voisins le bretonneux
retomber en enfance le temps d'une
exposition dédiée aux jouets anciens
une plongée dans le passé de 1897 1980
déjouer culte ou oubliées devenus de
vrais témoins de leur époque
un festival à vivre en famille à vélizy
ateliers parents-enfants un sapin de
noël artistiques et des spectacles le
point avec mélanie sur les différentes
activités proposées
le marathon des marchés de noël se
poursuit ce week end à plaisir ça
commence samedi jusqu'à dimanche 10
décembre une patinoire manège une mini
ferme seront installés dans le parc du
château à magny les hameaux rendez vous
dimanche au pôle musical blaise pascal
dès 10 heures le père noël vous recevra
à 15 heures autre rendez vous habituel
et solidaire du mois de décembre le
téléthon 31e édition ce week end
collectivités associations bénévoles de
saint quentin en yvelines sont mobilisés
mais aussi les sportifs à
saint-cyr-l'ecole la piste andy cabreira
à villa va tenter de battre un nouveau
record dans la piscine aqua mundo pour
récolter des fonds
après avoir réalisé six heures puis 12
heures de nage en apnée pour l'édition
2016 il s'attaque à une nouvelle
barrière celle des 24 heures des
animations sont également prévues en
parallèle où les coûte au micro de
michael et demi d'euros à partir de
18h30
il y aura des baptêmes d'amener des
cours d'aquagym des cours d'aquabike des
challenges de natation des challenges de
longueur l'abonné tout ça pour le
téléthon dès 18h30 et jusqu'à minuit
donc espérer landreau
dans rome et soutenir et aussi participé
à cette cause pour le téléthon il y à 50
ans jour pour jour la première course
cycliste du monde était organisée entre
paris et versailles le 8 décembre 1867
un groupe de passionnés s'est lancé le
défi de revivre cette épreuve à la mode
de l'époque sur d'authentiqués
vélocipède des années 1860
ce dimanche 10 décembre une vingtaine de
participants partiront de paris à 9
heures arrivée prévue à versailles sur
la place d'armes vers midi ils seront en
costumes d'époque et vous attendent
nombreux pour les accueillir les
organisateurs étaient présents sur notre
plateau jeudi 7 décembre
ils nous ont parlé de l'histoire de
cette course elle était relativement
méconnu jusqu'à ce qu'un historien
japonais du nom de kenzo kobayashi la
révèle puisque il était passionné de
vélo il a compris que la france était le
berceau du vélo et donc il est venu
étudier tous les documents d'archivés il
a produit une thèse en 1993 extrêmement
intéressante qui fait aujourd'hui
référence dans le monde qui s'appelle
vélocipède de drea michaud mythes et
réalités et à cette occasion là il a
révélé que
avant la course de saint cloud qui était
réputé la première d'accord en 1868
avait eu lieu cette course de paris à
versailles
[Musique]
une semaine consacrée à la musique
baroque à montigny le bretonneux
jusqu'au 16 décembre le pôle musique et
théâtre de la ville organise plusieurs
temps forts autour de cette thématique
conférences rencontres mais aussi
surtout des concerts le directeur du
pôle musique et théâtre va nous parler
de la programmation bonjour antoine
boesch bonjour alors on va déjà rappelé
en ce cas le baroque pour nos
spectateurs donc c'est un mouvement
artistique du 16e au 18e siècle
un style qui se caractérise par la
grandiloquence notamment en architecture
et en décoration et parmi les
compositeurs emblématique en france on à
jean baptiste lully et pour ce qui est
de la description de la musique par
contre je vais vous laisser nous en
parle et antoine boesch car c'est votre
spécialité
quelle est la particularité de la
musique baroque et pourquoi avoir voulu
dédier une semaine alors c'est la
particularité de cette semaine c'est la
rencontre avec un artiste françois
lazarevitch qui justement ont fait le
pont entre les musiques de tradition
orale à savoir la musique traditionnelle
et la musique baroque car à cette époque
la composante d'improvisation
venus des traditions orales est très
présente et c'est sur ce point que nous
avons assisté un peu sur cette semaine
et comment ce qu'on peut caractériser la
musique baroque qu'est ce qu'il fait
qu'est ce qu'il fait en musique baroque
à la musique baroque c'est la musique un
peu de l'expression du débordement
deux des passions et c'est une musique
qui est notamment d'un point de vue
pédagogique et de la rencontre avec les
élèves
quelque chose un moment fort qui va bien
au-delà de ce qu'on peut imaginer des
musiques dites classiques parce que
c'est une musique qui date mais qui est
encore très vivante et vous l'avez dit
françois lazarevitch a invité d'honneur
du coût de cette semaine ça commence du
coup sam 19 décembre avec une conférence
pour les élèves du conservatoire de
musique
absolument on a une conférence pasteur
classe c'est à dire que c'est à la fois
une rencontre un peu privilégié entre
cet artiste et des élèves qui ont
travaillé des pièces sur lequel le front
sur les arbitres tu vas les conseiller
et leur apporter toute la richesse de
son de son vécu d'artistes voilà
notamment au sein de sa compagnie
les musiciens de saint-julien est le
public aura également l'occasion de le
rencontrer mais en concert le 16
décembre à 20h30 voilà un concert qui va
se passer en deux parties avec une
première partie d'élèves et une deuxième
partie de récital de fonctionnaires et
beach dont on va profiter pleinement
puisque on aura l'occasion de découvrir
l'ensemble de ses talents de notamment
par le biais des flûtes baroques mais
aussi de la musique baroque
une sorte de cornemuse baroque on
connaît relativement peu et on va avoir
un répertoire assez riche parce qu'il va
piocher dans différents pays on aura de
la musique baroque française allemande
et même irlandaise oui absolument
c'est ce que je disais au début le pont
entre la musique allant des
qu'on connaît bien et l'improvisation
qui va autour c'est assez amusant de
voir les similitudes qui peut y avoir
entre ses musiques qu'on imagine à
s'éloigner qui au bout du compte sont
assez proches et pour se mettre en
appétit et justement on va peut-être
écouter un petit extrait de musique
baroque irlandaise interprété par
françois lazarevitch avec les musiciens
de saint-julien
on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
alors ça évoque beaucoup de choses on
l'a entendu ça nous arrive vraiment à
voyager oui absolument
c'est une musique d'ailleurs qui voyage
beaucoup
ce répertoire qui est à la fois un
répertoire écrit est à la fois
répertoire de tradition orale a beaucoup
voyagé et on voit d'ailleurs des formes
musicales qu'on retrouve à travers toute
l'europe
des thèmes qu'on retrouve à travers
toute l'europe est effectivement cette
musique qui voyage beaucoup et avant ce
concert depuis celle du cese il y aura
les élèves qui donneront un concert
également le 13 décembre en l'église
saint martin absolument c'est la
première fois pour nous première date
dans cette église saint martin donc on
va pouvoir bénéficier d'une acoustique
vraiment intéressante cette île voilà
voilà
et qui va permettre voilà aux élèves de
pouvoir s'y exprimer cette semaine
effectivement est un temps fort avec
différentes choses comme vous venez de
le dire de master class de concerts dont
c'est dans une église ou ou à la salle
jacques brel
voilà on aime bien pour donner le plus
de possibilités possible les élèves
faire des temps forts qui rythment un
peu la vie de notre équipement merci
beaucoup antoine boesch pour toutes ces
précisions
donc on le rappelle la semaine baroque
commence de la musique baroque ça
commence à samedi 9 décembre jusqu'au 16
deux concerts à ne pas manquer je vous
invite à vous rapprocher du pôle musique
et théâtre pour retrouver toutes les
informations merci beaucoup merci à vous
si vous avez été bercé dans votre
enfance par casimir les premiers d'ego
ou encore les poupées parisienne le
reportage qui va suivre devrait vous
intéresser
une grande exposition de jouets anciens
est programmé jusqu'au 20 décembre à
voisins le bretonneux un reportage pour
les petits et les grands écrit par
michael et demi d'euros un véritable
voyage dans le temps
depuis le 2 décembre la maison de covile
de voisins-le-bretonneux organise une
exposition gratuite sur les jouets
anciens
pour les petits et les grands plus de
deux mille cinq cents objets sont
exposés dans cette caverne d'ali baba
pour collectionneurs vous retrouvez tous
les jouets de 10 de 1880 à 1980 à peu
près c'est la nostalgie je le vois dans
le regard des adultes plus que presque
que les enfants encore jia les adultes
qui ont des les yeux comme des billes en
retrouvant le télécran ou en retrouvant
casimir ça ça fait plaisir
vraiment c'est une expo où les gens
arrivent avec le sourire à la porte
parmi les 200 m² de l'exposition les
visiteurs peuvent découvrir une maquette
légaux de cent mille pièces ou encore
des jouets rares comme ce jeu de pêche à
la ligne datant de 1890 le jeu de la
pêche à la ligne consistait premièrement
à faire entendre la sonorité aux enfants
et deuxièmement aller pêcher des objets
avec un aimant le luth c'est de pêcher
l'objet avant que l'objet ne passent sur
le pont donc l'objet donc l'enfant
empêcher un objet il le prenait
regardait et là ils avaient péché par
exemple effectivement une chaussure en
bois en fer blanc en plastique ou en
métal les jouets permettent également
aux visiteurs d'observer une part de
l'histoire selon les organisateurs
j'étais assez frappé par la fille qui
avait le fer à repasser la machine à
laver et la dînette et le garçon qui
jouait plutôt aux gendarmes et aux
voleurs
aux petites voitures et puis garçon qui
avait un mec qui est la fille un peu
moins je trouve voilà c'était en
préparant sa c'est ça qui m'a frappé
l'exposition se déroule du mardi au
dimanche jusqu'au 20 décembre une excuse
pour retomber définitivement en enfance
al'approche des fêtes de noël encore
quelques jours à patienter avant que le
père noël ne dépose ses cadeaux au pied
du sapin
à londres le centre d'art le centre oui
le centre d'art de vélizy villacoublay
on propose des ateliers sapin bonjour
mesdames bonjour caméline depuis le 2
décembre il y a comme un air de famille
qui flotte au centre d'art béliziens
alors un air de famille c'est le nom du
festival c'est un instant à vivre vous
l'aurez compris en famille qui a ponctué
l'atelier parents enfants autour du
sapin de noël
betty mais ce n'est l'artiste qui s'en
chargent de l'expliquent
nous allons créer sur le sol mon
parcours avec pour matière première des
rubans adhésifs coloré voilà donc on va
faire un parcours qui ira d'une pièce à
une autre peut-être on s'arrêtera sur
certaines s'arrêteront sur des pièces
qu'ils ont préféré
on créera comme ça des chemins des
trajets qui vont d'une pièce à une autre
une oeuvre collective éphémère qui sera
fait avec du ruban utilisé par les
électriciens mais dans son interview
betty parle aussi de pièces mais parce
que le début de l'atelier commencera
avec une visite des oeuvres de deux
artistes groupes et mazeas autour du
père noël et de cette époque magique
le public pourra voir des photos et le
blouson du père noël
un père noël biker alors pour l'occasion
ils ont aussi créé un majestueux sapin
qui trône dans le hall de londres
un sapin tout en irlande c'est une mini
forêts en un seul arbre et
à se perdre parce que nous on aime bien
et c'est 2 2
de renforcer vos moins d'établir un lien
entre quelqu'un qui viendrait voir une
exposition et le bel objet qui proposait
en fait si on ressert un petit peu les
liens voilà c'est du coup très resserrée
s'est tellement resserré
qu'effectivement on vient se perdent
directement dans la structure les
ateliers ont lieu tous les mercredis et
les samedis jusqu'au 20 décembre
et dans ce festival il ya aussi des
ciné-concerts le 15 décembre ce sont les
triplettes de belleville et comme c'est
la fin de cette ut loisirs je vous
propose de nous quitter avec un extrait
merci mélanie nous a reparlé de ce
festival on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là c'est un excellent week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]